a lot of people know about the paypal
mafia how the early team at paypal went
on to found and control some of the
biggest tech companies today but did you
know there is a much more powerful
influential business mafia out there one
stemming from a much more shady company
than paypal who assume much higher
positions of power all over the world
it's called the goldman sachs mafia this
is henry paulsen henry was a very
powerful man he was the former us
secretary of the treasury which meant he
controlled pretty much every aspect of
the federal government's finances and
during the 2008 financial crisis he was
pretty much the person in charge of the
entire bailouts he had the pleasure of
choosing who to keep afloat and who to
let drown in their own debts he was the
guy who essentially let lehman brothers
implode and the guy who made sure aig
the insurance company got enough money
in their bailout to pay goldman sachs 13
billion dollars his pedigree he spent 32
years at goldman sachs and from 1999 to
2006 he was both as chairman and ceo
then there's robert rubin bill clinton's
former treasury secretary who oversaw
the loosening of underwriting
regulations that had been in place since
the 30s this made it just so much easier
for investment banks to bend the rules
when it comes to taking companies public
his pedigree 26 years at goldman sachs
even becoming the co-chairman in 1990
the former heads of the canadian and
italian national banks former goldman
sachs employees
steve muchin treasury secretary under
donald trump
served 16 years at goldman sachs robert
zolick former president of the world
bank was a managing director at goldman
sachs joshua bolton george bush's chief
of staff served as an executive director
at goldman sachs for five years duncan
neider roar former ceo of the new york
stock exchange was also a partner at
let's say it together
goldman sachs
the european central bank the national
bank of greece the bank of england all
have employees with deep roots at
goldman in total more than 26 former
goldman sachs employees have taken
positions of incredible power and
influence all over the world the world
seems to be almost ruled by the alumni
of what is generally thought of as the
most slimy the most corrupt investment
bank in the world but how did it get to
this point
this is the goldman sachs mafia
goldman sachs goldman sachs goldman
sachs goldman sachs balloons that were
blamed for the worst financial crisis
since the great depression was hit today
with a record fine of
550 million dollars goldman sachs which
had a controversial role in the global
financial meltdown one of the giants at
the center of that bailout his former
employer toxic and destructive those
bribes in turn resulted in 2.7 billion
dollars in losses to one mdb
traditionally getting access to the best
investments in asset managers met trying
to get your foot in the door with the
wall street giants like goldman sachs
but unless you were rich that wasn't
happening
that didn't sit well with a few smart
people who decided to bridge that divide
so they built titan today time manages
over 750 million dollars for over 35 000
clients that are just like you titan is
basically like the advent of commission
free stock trading apps but for hedge
funds it gives you access to an
award-winning investment team in the
palm of your hands with zero performance
fees no lock ups a flat rate advisory
fee and record-breaking returns plus is
backed by companies like general
catalyst box group and celebrities
including jared leto will smith and
kevin durant all you have to do to get
started is download the app sign up and
deposit just a hundred dollars and boom
you get access to some of the best
investment strategies out there for
anything from usb stocks to crypto
assets to international stocks titan's
unique strategy of identifying a rare
species of stocks known as compounders
and hanging on tight has allowed them to
outperform all the major indices and
robo-advisors since their inception and
it's not just another etf or mutual fund
you know exactly where your money is at
all times because the team explains
every move they make with real-time
video updates all it takes is 100 to get
you on the road to smart investing so if
you want to get in on titan's
award-winning strategies go to titan.com
jake to get your first three months of
expert investment in asset management
for zero fees that's titan.com jake for
90 days free thanks to tyne for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
goldman sachs had humble beginnings cue
the typical grassroots backstory of an
underdog making it against all odds the
firm was originally started by marcus
goldman in 1869 and for the first 100 or
so years of his existence it was a
pretty regular yet very successful
financial firm marcus goman immigrated
to the us in 1848 and started brokering
ious for entrepreneurs and startups
basically he had clients who would give
him money he would then use that money
to issue small loans in the form of
short-term ilus to people who wanted to
start businesses almost immediately
after starting goldman managed to
transact up to five million dollars
worth of these ious a year in 1882
goman's son-in-law samuel sacks joined
the business and the name was officially
changed to what we know it as today
business boomed and within just a few
years goldman sachs was turning over 30
million dollars worth of ious in a year
and had over a hundred thousand dollars
in capital around 2.7 million dollars in
today's money goldman sachs was the
quintessential american dream come true
the family-owned firm built itself up
from nothing and by the time the boom of
the 1920s came around it was ready to
start making some serious money
[Laughter]
[Music]
goldman sachs started taking a dark turn
when it entered the ipo market of 1906
helping take cirrus public
the only reason gomen even got the deal
was because henry goldman marcus
goldman's son was close friends with the
owner of sirius suddenly a lot of bank's
focus shifted from issuing ilus to
helping companies go public a process
called underwriting
as an ipo underwriter goldman sachs
helped decide the initial offering price
of the stocks that were going public and
then they would take them public and
during a time when massive companies
like fw woolworth and continental cam
were going public being a firm that
provided ipo underwriting services was
very profitable and so started a bunch
of convoluted financial alchemy to
swindle the public out of their money
in every bubble there's usually some new
magical financial instrument that people
are going crazy over in 2008 it was
mortgage-backed securities today it
could be a bunch of stuff in the crypto
space but back then leading up to the
crash of 1929 and the great depression
the financial tool that was getting all
the hype were investment trusts so first
goldman created the goldman sachs
trading corporation an investment trust
they launched shares at a hundred
dollars per piece bought all those
shares with their own money and then
sold 90 of them to the public for 104
they were basically underwriting their
own company which is more than a little
sketchy but they did it anyways and made
a sweet profit from it too but that
wasn't enough the goldman sachs trading
corporation started buying up its own
shares back from the public pushing
share prices higher and higher when the
price was high enough they sold the
shares back to the public again
profiting the difference again and then
they sponsored a new trust the
shenandoah corporation it was basically
a legal pump and dump where they would
repeatedly pump up the price themselves
the shenandoah corporation started
issuing millions of dollars of shares
soon after its creation they did the
same thing there and eventually
sponsored the creation of another trust
called the blue ridge corporation
goldman sachs had created what was
essentially an investment pyramid scheme
7.25 million shares were issued by blue
ridge and 6.25 million of those shares
were owned by shenandoah and shenandoah
was basically owned by gomen trading so
gomen hid behind goldman who hid behind
goldman and they made a lot of money
doing it
they would just use all the funds to
public put into one trust to start a new
one to make even more money the only
problem was if one of the trust suddenly
lost value you wouldn't be able to pay
back the people selling their shares and
the whole pyramid would be massacred
which was pretty much exactly what
happened in the stock market crash of
1929. goldman sachs lost the equivalent
of 475 billion dollars in today's money
which damaged the bank's liquidity but
it also took out a lot of its
competition all the smaller first i had
invested with gomen before the crash
were basically wiped out leaving goldman
sachs to enjoy an almost
competition-free playground for a good
half a century afterwards it wouldn't be
until the late 90s that gomen would come
across such a lucrative opportunity like
the 20s again
[Music]
by the 90s goldman sachs was the
underwriter for some of the biggest
organizations in the country since the
stock market crash it had built a
reputation of being one of the best
investment banks in america the goldman
sachs of the early 90s played the long
game but that all changed when robert
rubin the former co-chairman of goldman
sachs became the treasury secretary and
the director of the national economic
council whether it was intentional or
not putting such a big supporter of
goldman sachs in the white house meant a
lot of leeway for the bank to color
outside the lines robert rubin did
nothing to regulate the sudden mass
underwriting goldman sachs started
companies that consisted of not much
more than a couple ideas scribbled on a
napkin were suddenly being taken public
via ipo these dot com startups were
hyped up in the media and so for
millions to the public who had no idea
they were buying into nothing how could
this happen since 1930 there have been
very strict worlds when it came to
underwriting a company had to be in
business for five years and showed three
years of being profitable but it looked
like goldman sachs and pretty much all
of wall street had thrown this rule out
the window all thanks to ruben who
didn't seem to care whether his old
friends and colleagues made millions by
not following the same regulations he
was supposed to be enforcing and goldman
sachs took advantage as much as they
could its analysts were telling people
that shares were worth a hundred dollars
even when they knew their clients would
be losing money in the end and the bank
took a mix of good and bad companies
public including yahoo web van and
e-toys some made money others crashed
and burned
goldman sachs were the ipo kings of the
internet age and they were making
billions off the mania eventually the
music stopped and a dot-com bubble burst
wiping out five trillion dollars on the
nasdaq alone goldman sachs got a measly
slap on the wrist and a 110 million fine
but for a company that was paying 7
billion a year in salaries alone that
fine was just a fee for doing business
with a new taste for profiting off of
economic crises goldman sachs was ready
for the next bubble
are you directing us to put lehman into
bankruptcy
[Music]
just like the drop in underwriting
standards in the 90s the early 2000s
brought even looser regulations except
this time it was around mortgages in the
90s people who wanted to buy houses had
to meet a lot of criteria they had to
put at least a 10 down payment on the
house proved that they had stable income
and have a good credit score but then
when the 2000s came along that got
thrown out the window too suddenly
everyone with a bank account could buy a
house a bunch of bad mortgages were
bundled together by investment banks
like goldman into mortgage-backed
securities and to hide the ticking time
bomb they were selling goldman would get
companies like aig to provide insurance
for the mortgage bundles called credit
default swaps if people defaulted on
their mortgages aig would reimburse
goldman so the potential mortgage
defaults would be swapped from goldman
to aig and all of this was made possible
by robert rubin who made sure congress
passed an act protecting investment
banks rights to continue selling
mortgages even though they knew there
was a big chance buyers wouldn't be
getting any money from them and
companies like aig would have to make up
the difference when the bubble bursted
goldman sachs profited big time and when
everything went down the drain they
turned to aig and said well you insured
all these securities for us time to pay
up and that's where henry paulson comes
in after three decades at goldman sachs
henry paulsen stepped down as the
chairman and ceo of goldman to become
the treasury secretary of the united
states in 2007. announce that i will
nominate henry paulsen to be the
secretary of the treasury
just a year later he was goldman sachs
knight in shining armor paulson was the
guy who chose not to help lehman
brothers one of goldman's competitors
when they were going down he was also
the guy who made sure that as soon as
lehman sank a 700 billion dollar bailout
package was created and he made extra
sure that aig who owed goldman sachs the
insurance money for defaulting mortgages
had enough cash injected in them to
repay goldman the 13 billion dollars
they owed goldman sachs ended up being
paid in full for its bad bets all thanks
to a friend in a very high place
but that wasn't all in order to get even
more bailout money goldman sachs was
converted from an investment bank to a
bank holding company it got 10 billion
dollars in relief it came under the
regulation of stephen freeman an
ex-goldman sachs employee and could
still afford to pay its employees 11
billion dollars in bonuses in the first
half of 2009.
goldman sachs didn't suffer at all
goldman sachs has had its best years
since the mortgage meltdown and since
the worldwide economic crisis they knew
their mortgages would fail they never
told anyone and what was goldman sachs
punishment for hiding the true value of
mortgages that had sold returning a
measly 14 million dollars to the
treasury less than a third of the ceo's
salary that same year and paying a few
pathetic fines in the tens of millions
which again is the cost of doing
business remember for goldman to be
winners there had to be losers
[Music]
after 2008
people were obviously reluctant to put
their money into any more convoluted
financial instruments so gomen had to
find something more real more physical
so they turned to the commodities market
when gas prices hit four dollars and
eleven cents a gallon in 2008 the
government wrote it off as having an
issue with supply but it was far from
the truth the supply of crude oil had
actually been increasing and demand
decreasing so the price of gas should
have gone down if it wasn't for goldman
sachs you see goldman and a lot of other
powerful firms had switched to trading
oil futures basically they were getting
the same pension funds and other big
investors from the housing mania to
agree to buy oil at a certain price on a
certain dates so oil futures became the
go-to tool for goman and other big banks
to speculate on and by 2008 a barrel of
oil was traded 27 times before actually
being delivered and used and with each
trade the price increased eventually
people owned more future barrel oils
than there were actual barrels of oil in
existence goldman promised people ever
increasing oil prices and when in mid
2008's crude oil prices dropped from 147
to 33 dollars goldman decided it was
time to bail and once again the losers
were regular people who couldn't get out
before the drop
just one pension fund the california
public employees retirement system had
1.1 billion dollars in commodities when
the crash came and crazy oil prices have
pushed food costs up so high that more
than 100 million people around the world
were forced into hunger and it was all
thanks to goldman sachs
[Music]
anyone else
through the years goldman sachs has been
accused of dozens of different crimes or
violations there's literally an entire
wikipedia page just titled goldman sachs
controversies if you want to go down
that rabbit hole kickback brass insider
trading intentionally undervaluing ipos
and putting their own interests in front
of their clients that's just some of
what goldman sachs has been accused of
over the years and it eventually got so
bad that the vice president of one of
goldman sachs departments a guy named
greg smith wrote a public letter of
resignation now i don't know if greg
smith had anything to gain with
resigning publicly and going on a bunch
of interviews but he does give us a rare
glimpse into the behemoth
when people leave goldman they tend to
do it quietly greg smith is talking for
the first time about what led him to
leave the firm and to do it in such a
public way it makes me ill how callously
people talk about ripping their clients
off goldman sachs and other firms on
wall street started learning how to use
the information they were getting from
their clients in order to bet with their
own money at times betting against their
clients the quickest way to make money
on wall street is to take the most
sophisticated product and try to sell it
to the least sophisticated client in
europe a muppet is a term for someone
you can manipulate someone who is an
idiot wall street isn't exactly known
for taking the moral high road when it
comes to profits but goldman sachs has
proven to be the best at taking this to
an extreme
wall street ethics is a sort of oxymoron
people who work at goldman sachs don't
talk about working at goldman sachs
there's like fight club
it is a little bit or maybe like the
mafia that people are reluctant to talk
about what's happened there you are
betting against the very product you are
selling and you're just not troubled by
it i'm sorry i can't endorse your
characterization
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you